everyone hello hello welcome to
simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on and today I'm
sitting down with David Ewing Duncan
hello hey how's it going I'm pumped to
Josias it's gonna be a blast awesome I
love the spot by the way ooh great view
of the bay yeah yeah good view of the
bay we got our epic director Ron Vargas
in the back shout out to him he's
crushing it we are also in bio trillions
health tech company right now they're an
emerging one out of San Francisco and we
are very grateful for their location and
sponsorship they're Lincoln's in the bio
as well simulation we're pairing
together global leaders with humanity's
most thought-provoking questions so
we're gonna be talking about it all
David is a author he's a journalist he's
an entrepreneur I love talking to him
this is gonna be epic so let's just jump
right into it I mean this is a live
stream so feel free to comment and share
we'll see what you guys are talking
about on it okay I love asking this
question to start it all off and I just
want to know we're simulated right we
are so this isn't really yes yes
simulation okay got it okay yes yes okay
let's we'll get into that more I know
okay how do we maximize human potential
okay that's a it's a wildly broad
question but I guess you know that's
obviously something that I've been
fascinated with as a writer and I think
fascinated with from a lot of different
points of view I mean out here in the
Bay Area where we are I think a lot of
people think of it as technology but I
think it would also you know politically
from a policy standpoint from how we are
as humans and you know we right now need
this rather desperately you know how do
we maximize what's best about humans I
mean there's some things that aren't so
great about humans - yes but you know so
I think of it more in a much broader
sense and I'm a historian by training
and it's been interesting to watch the
sweeps of history it tends to kind of go
up and down on how well we're doing and
you know we've been on a little bit of a
run here the last few decades arguably
you know and trying to improve things
around the world
of problems but you know we're in one of
those interesting moments now where
where are we gonna go so I think the
technology I'm not sure what you're
expecting here but technology is only
part of the equation the equation what
else what are the other components well
like I said it's yeah I mean policy I
think we are in a desperate desperate
desperate state now politically mmm that
the systems that we have and have been
very successful especially since say
World War two you know they were
invented back in 18th century they've
been updated a couple of times I've
written about this here and there you
know probably last in the 60s you know
starting with Kennedy or even before
that post-war period we kind of upgraded
it to allow government to help say
develop a lot of the technologies that
we're now using I mean early on people
don't like to admit this sometimes we
even remember it but the internet you
know space with NASA any number of
things came out of a collaboration
between what you might refer to as
society and Anna govern as represented
in the government and private the
private sector and really smart people
and I think we need to I think it's
actually is important to figure out how
to update that for the 21st century as
it is all the other technologies of
Oregon so collaboration is a huge
component between was that also
applicable to between nations as well
are we should we should we maybe mask
the some of the smartest people across
the world to work on something like AI
and on something like health care and
transportation etc or should it be how
much nationalism should there be within
capitalism you know what do you think
there I don't know I am a both the
pragmatist and would-be optimist on all
of that I mean III the optimist in me or
I guess you know the kind of hope for
future in me thinks that we probably are
heading towards or should be heading
towards a more global approach to this
but you have to recognize I mean that's
been tried and there's been a lot of
utopian thinking of
about that but the reality is if people
do still start with their family and
tribe and the question is whether that
tribe can be expanded it can be a
positive kind of interaction with other
tribes or not yeah and so I think you're
naive if you're thinking that there you
know a globalization will solve
everything and then nationalism will go
away I think we're actually seeing now
that that we thought maybe globalism was
taking over but in fact nationalism is
still really so I think it has to be
recognized and has to be thought about
and dealt with creatively but clearly
there is this kind of global phenomenon
I mean we think of it the global elite
but there's and you know that definitely
exists but okay that's actually one of
our questions so maybe we should just
quickly address that along the way is
you said there clearly exists of global
elite that's one of our questions is is
there a global ruling elite that I think
they're in Davos right now they're deaf
yeah right as we speak and at the World
Economic Forum right exactly
okay and but now for example the
Rothschild family is not there right oh
yeah no not everybody goes to dab of
that every okay okay and you know there
are different elements of this global
elite and you know essentially it's a
bunch of rich people it's not always the
case I mean Davos has a reputation a lot
of rich people go there but it's also
innovators and kind of you know a lot of
interesting people but it's not all of
them by any means I mean you and I
aren't there you're way cooler I don't
know I mean you know I was barely going
this year but that doesn't mean anything
yeah you should be there well I don't I
mean there's a lot of interesting stuff
that that happens there yeah and you
know there are other meetings like that
but you know there's definitely a global
elite as a historian I can tell you
there's always been a global in weather
here an ancient Mayan or Roman or you
know whatever civil training period you
are in right and the way most societies
work is there is a sort of an elite used
to not be such a bad word I mean
now you think of it more of like you
know the 1% of the point of 1% you know
making all the money or the rest of us
don't but you know elite historically
means that there's there's a group to
kind of run stinks mm-hmm and in ancient
societies which are mostly illiterate
and you know mostly there were workers
and then there was a small group at the
top you know you're like you think of
medieval Europe there was you know the
aristocrats and the king and then
everybody else and that's always existed
and one might argue that the people that
run our civilization it's a much larger
broad I mean its millions and millions
of people probably tens of millions of
people that you you know if you took
those people away everything would stop
work yeah but you'd have to take a lot
of them away for it to stop working yeah
yeah whereas like the Mayans there's a
theory that you know the well they
collapsed actually two or three times
but they no longer exist and you know
most of their civilization is buried
under jungle it's because something
happened to that elite that knew how to
run things and you know their various
theories about how that happened it kind
of happened in Rome I mean eventually
the economics the barbarian invasions
and the economics kind of began to
whittle away at this group that ran
things so anyway that can I say that it
should be important then for the people
that are in charge to explain some of
the systems how they work two people
that are also close to them that way in
case something happens that there's not
just an observable ization can't
function anymore moment oh yeah in fact
you know that's one of the reasons why
it's so concerning right now that
Science and Technology are under assault
and the truth really I mean this whole
fake news thing which seems to me news
it's inconvenient to certain people you
know usually the truth that's
inconvenient but that's the most
important thing I mean you you know it
is education and making sure there's a
group of people that know how things run
but you also have to have a fundamental
respect for facts and
truth and science exactly and even if
it's uncomfortable for you politically
and so you know again you know all of
these issues that you discuss of these
these wonderful life casts here I I kind
of come back at them in a little bit of
a political or societal view because
that's where yeah my background is in
history and I covered politics as a
journalist so that's that's global elite
though it's we're in a funny period but
it's almost surreal actually because in
the one hand I think there is this
global culture let's not call them
elites because it is a is a lot a lot of
people and you know most people in most
big cities for instance in the West
anyway and a lot of people even outside
of the west or educated or those who are
educated there's a certain system that
they share a certain set of facts a lot
of people even you know use certain set
languages like English to communicate
you know a lot of people use Chinese and
their their other language is Spanish so
there's sort of languages that people
recognize and can communicate in and
these these are all requirements to have
a sort of global sensibility and there's
a kind of shared culture that I don't
know if you've read the book sapiens
yeah but yeah and you know he describes
us as being these fictions basically
that we've all decided that we believe
in correct and when you stop believing
in them everything goes to [ __ ] like how
intersection works intersection with
traffic lights and and vehicles and
pedestrians etc yeah stop believing in
it it turns to crap yeah yeah
same thing same thing with money it's a
global hallucination that this piece of
paper is worth a certain amount of money
and that gives you certain good well
pretty much everything we've agreed on I
mean you know why do we drive on the
right side of the road in certain
countries the left side of the road and
you really we just kind of it I guess
it's law but we've also just decided
that that's what we want to do it
you know we think it's totally natural
to do that to use toilet paper on our
bubbles whatever but what by the way
that's not used in everywhere right
everywhere yeah yeah it's not a shared
fiction necessarily but I I think that
they're they're more people than ever in
history alive right now and as a
percentage there are more people that
are have bought in to that system but
like like I keep saying it it's under a
lot of stress right now you know because
there are a lot of people left out and
this is where it is right this division
between the really uber elite that
really high-level that's making a you
know more money than that group has made
an essential product to go back to the
roaring 90s 1890s maybe the 20s where
you had such a gigantic divide between
the very wealthy and even the next level
of wealth and so these are all these are
all issues but and we don't know really
which way it's gonna go
what's gonna happen with it so maybe we
can as we circle back to maximizing
potential I want to add a little bit
more to this global elite conversation
what's going on in Davos and the World
Economic Forum is very interesting when
you tune in and you hear what they're
talking about you're you're very
fascinated because you almost have have
had no training in those fields we're
running around on a daily basis not
really trained into understanding
geopolitics geo-economics we're not
talking about those things on a daily
basis so when you do get doses of them
you mean you might want to immerse
yourself more in them so as you were
just mentioning about how there might be
a it's already quite a big gap between
people that earn lots and lots of money
whereas people that just earn money like
decent money so my question then is
within the school ruling Li and the
trajectory of civilization or do you
think there might be a class-based
speciation well I was about to get to
that okay cool cool yeah the I mean I
think as we're seeing you know the
phenomenon Trump and some other sort of
populist nationalist those are always
kind of fuzzy terms but they're clearly
a lot of people are being left behind
and I would say even
that upper middle class of people that
are really running things actually I
mean that tiny tiny little upper elite
they're making money off of things and
they kind of own things and you know a
lot of wealth goes to them but the
people actually running things or feel
under stress anyway even though they're
making a lot more money than most people
but there is the group that's more or
less you know feel like anyway they've
been left behind I mean I think it's
yeah you know what they're what they're
really feeling is especially in the West
especially in United States the last two
or three generations really since the
Great Depression and the war World War
two each generation has felt improvement
over their parents yeah and what you're
getting now is that's that's slowed down
and the real wages for the United States
it's been pretty flat for decades really
and people aren't feeling like they're
improving even though they're living far
better than say their grandparents are
the great yes and this is beginning to
happen even in other parts of the world
too mostly first world mostly first
world but you are getting some areas you
know there's what I used to always call
a second and a half world right it's
it's not the third world a second and
yeah we don't even have communism very
much anymore which used to be the second
I mean depending on but it's just the
second world but you know countries that
clearly are not destitute and you know
are doing reasonably well you have a you
know a middle class in the context of
that country and they're feeling
stressed too and you know many of them
again as we're seeing with with Trump
and all of that are feeling not only
left a little left out but actually kind
of dispossessed or not being paid
attention to
yeah and that's not good that's know
that's you need recognition in tribes
and civilization yeah and I you know I
hate to say this because I have a lot of
friends I have a lot of money but you
know you you almost have to wonder how
much money does the top echelon really
need yeah yeah you know I actually have
a really interesting thought that I have
been talking about this class-based
speciation with with a couple people
that have been studying it for a while
is that
it could it potentially be a decent idea
to repress the amount of wealth that can
be accumulated and at first it's like no
no no no no let capitalism go that's
horrible
but at the same time here's my question
to address that point is that are we
purchasing a fifth boat with our money
or are we starting are we hiring 50
people to solve a problem in the world
with that money now so that's sort of
this school of thought is what are you
doing with the excess wealth and no
one's saying what you have to do we're
not forcing people but we're just saying
can we have a conversation about like
what could be better to do with the
excess amounts that's always no I you
know I mean again if you go back in
history there have been most of his
histories actually like this like I said
you have the very wealthy than everybody
else and you know but you have to look
and see why did it weigh have we been so
successful in the last few decades in
the West and especially the United
States I mean nobody's been as
successful as we have - now come yeah
sure others are coming up but one of the
reasons is that the pie you know classic
kind of economics for the last several
decades you the pie kept getting bigger
and everybody had their slice mmm and
and you know in that sense the wealthier
got wealthier but so did most other
people and what's happening now is the
slice of the very wealthy has gotten I
mean everything's still expanding you
know Donald Trump keeps talking about
this amazing stock market it is amazing
Jesus was 26,000 the Dow or something
unprecedented huge but yeah it just it
really makes that slice of that pie for
and I don't mean to harp on the very
wealthy but I will say that something in
Henry Ford said and Henry Ford you know
back when he started making surly
automobiles and before he became pretty
much
hesitate use the word fascist but he was
pretty right-wing you know it's um he
was rising and all that but he did make
a point that you know in the early 20th
century when they were sick they started
mass producing automobiles that he
needed to pay his workers enough that
they could actually afford one of his
cars so yeah these are the kind of
things that I think that that global
elite that's very wealthy he's sitting
at Davos should really think about
because what's the the tragedy that's
unfolding and I think I think that's not
too strong a word is that the the
wealthy in the world have kind of
disassociated themselves from the rest
of the world not realizing that their
wealth I mean one aspect of it is their
wealth actually comes from the rest of
those people and especially the newer
wealth mean everybody renting their
goods right yeah everybody talks about
scaling well you know how are you
scaling you're scaling by having
millions and millions of people buying
your products and again I I don't know
let's do a good quick example but oh the
people that made this building that were
sitting in right now they made it with
the intention that they were gonna sell
the individual units in the building and
make money on that and make another
beautiful skyscraper somewhere and keep
doing this process so it's the people
that have bought the units within the
building that have given them the excess
wealth so it's again it's it's reliant
on the people that are making the
decisions with their money that they're
earning to help them I think they're
pretty wealthy people mostly in this
building but but yeah but but the point
is well-taken I mean you know if wages
are flat are going down for most people
who buy the goods that the wealthy you
know depend on to create more wealth
that that becomes pretty unsustainable
and I had a really interesting
discussion with Tim O'Reilly of O'Reilly
media for the book I'm working on right
now and it it actually was a kind of
mind-blowing discussion which we can
talk more about because I know you want
to talk about the matrix or whatever
there's so many more times but this
one's amazing where we're at right now
so yeah the one thing that Tim's said
was that there's a site there's such
thing as as short-term greed or
long-term greed
and you know he's a he's a liberally you
know comes from Sonoma County and you
know he's pretty well known for his
politics but he said look I'm a
capitalist I really I think capitalism
you know under certain certain
circumstances is you know is a very
viable system to build the world that we
live in today right pretty much but he
said there's this short-term greed
versus long-term greed and he's sort of
meant like okay everybody's thinking
quarterly like that which you know is
normally what you think about was short
term grade but he's also talking about a
mentality said since World War two
mostly the wealthy and the people that
really make the civilization work I've
been thinking long term greed like how
can I kind of create a society that will
create wealth for me over time and it's
partly a community since it's more of a
community Sensibility
but it's not trying to just grab for
everything you can get like sure right
right now and he's seen a slow shift
over to the short term green and okay
let's give an example well I think you
know the the banks continue to try to
milk every you know dollar out of you
know every every instrument that they
create even those that as we found out
in the crash of 2008 2009
we're completely unsustainable I mean
they knew that yeah these people are not
strike the short term yeah what desire
yeah you know having these these
subprime loans and where people who
didn't have any money were you know
we're able to buy houses and get
mortgages one after another after
another after another I mean pretty much
anybody with a fifth grade education
could have figured out that that wasn't
gonna but a lot of people made money in
the short term yeah okay so what is this
transition to long term wealth
accumulation that people that are now in
the top 1% or even 1% of 1% that they
are now starting to think about how they
can work the systems of society to help
them over a long period of time make
more money but it does that also have
something to do with them
trying to better society at the same
time like you want to upgrade the
technology that built because of course
their kids will interact with kids from
other social classes hope hopefully I
guess but maybe maybe and and you you
want the rest of the world to not it's
actually in their best interest to not
leave the rest of the world in a place
of revolt or in a place of being upset I
would think you think yeah I mean that's
long-term greed thinking and you know
that place that you draw or - I mean
almost everybody who is an adult I think
everybody well everybody was an adult in
the 30s who remembers the rise of
fascism Nazism and communism
those were reactions to the Great
Depression into the excesses of the
early 20th century and one of the
reasons that you have this somewhat
boring you know system like the UN and
the EU and these different you know
unions and and governmental systems put
together after the war was to keep that
those kind of passions that caused
essentially revolts
I mean communism was a revolt literally
I mean if you take communism its face
the political philosophy is to overthrow
capitalism and they did I mean they
controlled large parts of the world you
know turned out to become authoritarian
and totalitarian it come out exactly the
way that yeah the original like Marx and
Engels would have thought yeah but which
could be what a utopia somewhat looks
like in a crazy it's funny anyway I
think it's mostly an analysis of
capitalism the short-term greed if you
want to look at it that way you know of
the late 19th century and and it was
extrapolated into the early 20th century
but we've kind of forgotten that now we
forgotten even like the Raizel I don't
know white supremacist I mean all of
that and you know we've forgotten what
it was like during that horrible period
when most of the world you know the
world was nearly destroyed ourselves
mm-hmm and there's still whatever 20,000
nukes on the planet whatever the hell
yeah what else before I mean we only
the two nukes at the end of the war but
the world war itself was pretty bad even
without nukes and you know I don't mean
to get too apocalyptic here but we do
have a pattern in history what yeah
things went really well for a while yeah
and we kind of forget what it was like
yeah yeah you know when we were kind of
screwing up and not doing things well
yeah and then we go into another period
where well things like what you're
asking about
all right there ec Asia there clear yeah
there clearly are a lot of really angry
people out there and they're even
willing to put up with Donald Trump and
you know and other other leaders brexit
in the UK I mean these to me are
expressions of incredible frustration by
people who feel ignored like they're
going backwards
and I do think that there let's we
forget with all the craziness of Donald
Trump and all that there is some truth
to that yeah you know there there is a
group that is sort of bifurcated out
over here and you know that kind of has
their own worldview and and talks you
know in their own echo chamber and the
best of them don't I mean you have there
are a lot of very wealthy people who are
doing great good in the world too and it
is kind of fun when you get like a Bill
Gates who was almost as Darth Vader
character when he you know at the end of
90s yeah you know he was running
Microsoft everybody yeah he was kind of
a jerk and then suddenly has this
transformation yeah and you know I you
can judge whether the money that they're
spinning in the Gates Foundation is you
know if it's being well spent
I know that but clearly the impetus is
there for a bunch of smart people to try
to do some good in the world and that's
that's not a bad thing yeah yeah it's
not a foundation just to say you have a
foundation it's not when you Alec well
it kind of is but that's okay I don't
care about he what he done he wanted to
do it to counter the Darth Vader image
which a lot of people think think it
doesn't matter I mean you know if it's
going for something that's positive it's
a good idea of what we just described as
taking your wealth and doing something
with it that you find to be meaningful
or an impact
for the world to leave behind a legacy
of that so do you think that it is
inevitable that there is some sort of a
over this next hill there's going to be
some sort of a potentially bifurcation
or trifurcation however many roads the
different socio-economic statuses get
sent down
what do you where do you see that sort
of going I think that we are really at a
crossroads and it's unknown I mean
that's that seems to be one trend that
could be happening on the other hand I
mean you read like Steven Pinker's book
on violence and it's such a good book
yeah I mean there there there's an
amazing amount of evidence and and
Barack Obama tried to talk about this I
think he talked about it actually
weirdly too much and he didn't talk
enough about you know the bad things
that were happening to people but
clearly the world as as an aggregate is
a much better off place than it was and
you know there there's less violence
certainly less war I mean these are just
facts
let's child mortality less disease
rights more technology longer lifespan
yeah more literacy things like that yeah
you know there but that's that's not the
full story
you know people it's interesting a long
time ago I wrote a piece for Atlantic on
its called out of Africa and it was
basically how everyone you know had
worked so hard on Africa to you know
deal with the really horrific situation
of of infant mortality thinks I confront
mortality and illiteracy and you know
basic health and I'd been a
correspondent over there and I you know
one of the things I just you know at
least observe for myself was that
everybody was so frustrated because I
couldn't really reach the next step and
all the money was kind of being pulled
out on a funny way at least for the old
system of going in a building giant
schools and factories and things like
that and the irony was that once people
got one or two steps above being
destitute and hungry and having a
about however they were gonna eat and
you know all the horrors of living in a
really really subsistence environment
then you had minimal health and minimal
food and minimal education then what
mm-hmm and most of the countries
especially then and some of them are a
little better now meaning or
fulfillments or so yeah what are you
gonna do what job are you gonna have
yeah correct correct and we've actually
gotten even to another step which is
meaning in life yeah correct yeah and to
be honest with you I think this is why
it's fertile ground for some of these
movements
you know like extremist movements you
know wherever you want to go with that
on the right or Isis or they're an awful
lot I spent some time in the Middle East
they're an awful lot of young men there
who are educated or at least partially
educated you know they're they're not
having to worry about you know basics in
life but they don't really there's not
really much for them there yeah correct
and there's not really an opportunity to
go to a boot camp for software
engineering yeah yeah I mean there's and
you know we have enough trouble here
with you know people that don't have
fulfilling jobs or you know jobs being
taken away because the technology but
imagine a country where you've got 30 or
40 percent unemployment of people 25 and
under correct
yeah that's insane it's insanity what
are you doing every day geez that's
where all this crap crappy stuff on the
streets comes from yeah mostly but I do
want to say I want to hastily add here
because I think again we have a lot of
smart people that are thinking about
this and I mean I just met a guy the
other day he was a Palestinian doctor
and he was at the NCI I believe he's an
American Palestinian American but I was
hearing about this new fund that the NIH
Bill Gates and several others put
together that was based in the Middle
East and in Africa I think in Nairobi
and they were trying to take some of
this stuff I work on
like molecular using genetics and
molecular biology to try to you know
increase wellness and keep people from
getting sick as much as possible correct
they want to take that to Africa and
Asia and you know you look it's right
word you're about to kind of get a
little bit despairing you you see
initiatives like that yeah and that's so
that's a exactly we were just talking
about it's a mix of government and a
rich guy yeah and you know private
sector correct yeah and you know that's
exciting
and they want to create a movement that
will be far beyond even though three
billion dollars or so that they've
raised yeah so that's why I'm amazing
but that's why we're gonna crossroads I
mean which way is it gonna go who knows
so you're you're right there's been a
lot of indication the past that life has
gotten so much better and I'm just
curious are people having these
conversations about the potential
trajectory of civilization in a way of a
socio-economic split I mean Hollywood's
done so much with these movies and stuff
but it just seems more and more real
when you're go to sixth Street in San
Francisco which has some issues near
Market Street or in render loin ish and
then you come into one of these
buildings and then you think to yourself
like whoa I mean of course genetics and
environment mold people into certain
scenarios and it's difficult to dig
yourself out of things like that
sometimes but holy cow and then there's
a whole level above even this and then
there's you know is there love above
that and what what are they talking
about
how what what what this initiatives like
what you just described are they talking
about things like that where is that
seems to be one of the most pressing
things in my opinion well I think there
is a lot of discussion I mean you know
despite the weird turn that our national
politics has taken in a funny way even
on that I think that's a gigantic
wake-up call you know I mean for
instance Democrats and liberals after
fighting these amazing battles during
the fifties and sixties into the 70s you
know around race and women's rights and
environmental rights and all of that is
sort of you know they won certain things
like yeah the EPA and you know Civil
Rights voting Voting Rights Act things
like that and they started retreated to
their coasts in the cities and they left
the rest of the country's sort of
ignored it and I think that yeah they
won't be ignoring it in the near geo
here and we it may be that we needed a
wake-up call and I'm giving away kind of
I guess my political leanings in a way
although I Center myself more of a
pragmatist
yeah it is yeah that's all yeah that's
right and you know maybe you know we
have to kind of survive this period here
which at least some people view it that
way or even if you you know like what's
going on you know it's a wake-up call
for that yes well interesting to know
yeah everything the people that like
what's going possible that in the midst
of this you know divisiveness and
partisanship that you will actually have
a better you know outcome emerge from
this wrecked I mean it you know we talk
yeah we talked earlier about politics
and policy needing revamping part of
what we need is to get smart people back
in politics you know it's been so this
thing talks about why don't we have any
engineers in politics why don't we have
it's not like they're not capable I mean
they can handle some of the most complex
math and science they build the systems
that people use every day why can't they
take positions inside of Congress well
I've written several pieces on this I
one of my favorites was was called
Thomas Jefferson would work for Google X
this was about three or four years ago
and I talked to Bill Maris you know who
used to head up Google Ventures and he
actually started out in government I
didn't know that at the NIH and
he went in to venture I said why aren't
you in government why aren't you trying
to I mean you're trying to solve certain
problems there Google Ventures and he
said cuz I don't feel like governments a
place that I would you know get much
traction and I'd like to go back and
talk to him now because I think he's
better yeah a bit of a sea change among
you know smart people who really have
grown up in a generation especially the
last generation that has seen you know
government kind of at its worse in many
ways and starting starting with Reagan
and I don't know and they're different
period I don't mean to blame one
ideology or the other one partier
together because there's been a lot of
government bashing and probably rightly
so but we the government is in a way us
and if it's course sort of screwing up
then we're screwing up and forget who's
in power even what your yeah ideology is
and I don't know I mean they talked
about the best and the brightest in the
60s and that sometimes used in an ironic
way now because they got us into Vietnam
and all of that but we they also
responsible for a lot of what our world
is today you know and on a positive side
yes like correctly like like we said
Internet yeah NASA Apollo program the
highway system I'm all the exits oh yeah
oh yeah and a cylinder it wouldn't it be
nice if we got some of the really smart
people that also have a social conscious
and a sense of community
yeah and this is what people like Tim
O'Reilly are working on with Code for
America and so again those are really
positive steps yeah but one outcome here
is know that is how to maximize some
potential things like yeah yeah that was
that that's a good back to the first
question and understand all the things
you listed kind of did just that
so what are those things of the two
thousand tens and twenties that are
going to do that yeah but you know out
out here in in the Bay Area you know the
last probably 20 30 40 years has become
so you know dimensional focused on
technology
and there's an enormous amount of wealth
here I mean this is not even though we
do have a couple spots left like the
Tenderloin which is I think now about
three blocks before box it's not you
know I mean most of this city is is
really it's a very very wealthy city but
I think that all of the things that are
happening in the world in this really
important moment that we're in where it
could go badly or well is getting
people's attention and again I've been a
huge person that's been saying good
attention pay attention correct yeah but
I I think you know democracy is as
Winston Churchill said you know it's the
worst form of government except all the
others and I'll always love that but
part of what he will their next yeah
part of what's next well what part of
what he meant was that democracies
really don't work very well unless
there's a crisis and then sometimes they
collapse because of the crisis but it
also can make them stronger mm-hmm and I
always wonder what's next in terms of
what kind of political structures next
so maybe we quickly address that is do
you think that democracy can be
modernized in a way that makes for a
better future um so you know created in
18th century it has managed to update
itself several times yeah and you know I
again if you did so much many more
disruptions that are happening now then
look at that in the Heat team I mean we
just got a car and some medicine and
stuff like that and now in airplanes and
stuff but now we have all with the
internet and computing and rockets and
well we haven't really talked about this
I mean the the pace of this exponential
pace and I don't entirely like that word
a lot of people use it but it is it's
fast and to me it's not only fast it's a
lot of things happening at once I mean
we've had technological change for the
last 500 years and you know we're still
here and even though we've had some ups
and downs but I do think that it works
best when we as society figure out ways
to allow technology you know freedom to
move forward but we watch closely and we
start you know we I mean I hate the word
use the word regulation
but certainly in healthcare where I'm in
you know you want people to be making
sure the drug you're taking isn't going
to kill you
and you know there are some good reasons
to have a certain amount of regulation
and I think you're about to see this
happen like with social media because
clearly the people have built social
media you know we love them for a long
time now we're like you know there's a
dark media there's the you know
interference in the elections there are
these other manipulations and abuses of
social media and how are we the people a
society going to control that I mean you
know I'm a person that's I haven't sworn
off of social media but I could I mean I
kind of see the dark side
the dark side is still enough of you
know positive I love you I'll
communicate my friends and all that kind
of stuff yes yes but yeah keep leaning
over but clearly something needs to
happen and this has happen again
periodically like in the roaring 90s in
the 1890s you know that part of that
came from new new technologies and
energy sources like oil and you know you
broke we broke up Standard Oil which you
know was almost because the government
at one time and you know this that was
at a pretty conservative time too but we
decided that if you want to look at like
government regulations or rules like
monopoly rules we decided that okay we
need a new monopoly world you know okay
you know yeah like you you you know
after after three rows you go to jail
not for maybe that's for before yeah and
that's part of what this is it's
creating a set of rules that everybody
has to follow and that most people agree
with and you know they keep the society
moving forward not stagnating you
brought up a good amount of these
examples of letting technology kind of
go forth and but then keeping a close
eye the society keeps a close eye on its
progress just in case so we just had a
day arrest see on here on on Friday last
week and
we were we had discussed kind of the
importance of maybe keeping these sorts
of Technology experiments because Jo had
mentioned that society isn't quite as
conscious as we'd like it to be I mean
we're not really some thirty year old
adult that's very conscious and aware
and and everything we're kind of like 13
year olds with firecrackers and stuff
like that and so yeah
and so with something like I love that
analogy was so good this was something
like maybe genetic engineering maybe we
need to keep it in a more closed setting
for now and test it for five years and
see how that works and then let it go
because if we do this no regulations
China hands-off thing and let it go
wherever it goes then yeah you might win
in some cases but Society this could be
an existential threat at the same time
well yeah it isn't in anything goes
China is a little bit different system
and they more and more worried about
this and in some cases like with AI they
may actually turn it towards you know
the state using that technology no
dating oh yeah a few people yeah I mean
many capitalists also think that which
in the in a nutshell kind of is
something to worry about because again
that we have we're playing with what is
what you know Google CEO said is but
more important than fire and electricity
and we're kind of just oh yeah yeah
playing I don't know no I mean yeah the
reality of gene-editing is whether you
know you think it should be anyone
should be able to use it or not is it
can be used it you know by many people
it's it's very simple or comparatively
simple yeah compared to earlier
techniques it's relatively cheap I mean
high school students are winning awards
using CRISPR cast nine oh yeah the Intel
three years ago
okay now the kid was working with George
Church is a major yes geneticist at
Harvard
he won one of the Intel Awards anyway
that's amazing science Awards as a high
school student that's a but but the
point is this you know we haven't had a
lot of people making nuclear bomb it's
not because I mean actually making the
bomb isn't that hard it's getting the
materials and handling them so you did
have a you know yeah kind of check there
on that really deadly technology but
Christopher cast 9 and other genetic
techniques are only going to get easier
and I I think that we as a society well
we're already thinking about it and you
know we you do worry that there's some
rogue lab somewhere that's going to do
something absolutely but you know this
is where again I have you know I think
the different ways this could go and I
even have mixed feelings about it on the
one hand it's really scary just like
nuclear materials getting in the hands
of a terrorist or somebody is really
scary on the other hand we you know we
have kind of muddled through we haven't
destroyed ourselves yet despite a lot of
apocalyptic movies you know we'll see
maybe you know maybe somehow we continue
to muddle through one can only hope I
wouldn't bet on that though I mean I
would like to have not 13 year olds
playing with firecrackers but maybe some
some of these smarter people were
talking about that and they are out
there they're really start fools talk
for smart people but they're like we're
thinking about all let's say real
they're really not yeah that not that
much more advanced because we solve so
many of these sort of issues that we see
I they're not all 15 I mean you know
what one of them fascinating things
about Christopher cast and I and you
know which by the way is this technology
that was you know
developed around 2012 and suddenly you
know we we could easily edit genes which
is before before you couldn't and one of
the co discoverers of that Jennifer
Doudna who's across the bay yeah over
there at Berkeley she and others did
something almost unprecedented among
scientists discoverers like her I mean
yeah sure bit out history is only look
great
covers definitely Watson and Crick and
all of that I would I would guess yeah
certainly in that group yeah she
essentially said whoa wait a minute a
couple years after or soon after her
discovery and said this is really scary
technology in fact she even in the book
that she wrote talked about having this
nightmare of being taken in to meet
Adolf Hitler who wanted to know about
our technology she's I mean that's great
I see hang out with a lot of science
scientists usually don't think that way
but she she and some other you know
people who were well over the age of
fifteen decided to hold but as meeting
work that was no I understand you know
I'm sort of meeting evening news that I
think that do they are okay yes more
like nine years old and like twelve
years old but because societies probably
the wisdom of children too but but they
you know they held a meeting and
actually declared a voluntary moratorium
on this technology which again
scientists don't it's only really
happened one other time in history which
had to do in the earlier form of genetic
engineering called recombinant DNA in
the 70s and they briefly had a
moratorium on that while they decided if
the and there's a there's a lot of
discussion and talk going on again at
that organizational level and some of it
is government in actually the National
Academy of Sciences sponsors some of
these meetings so that's government
money but this is what I was talking
about earlier this is a community of the
smartest people in those fields coming
together and discussing not just the
science or technology or how cool it is
or starting a new company but also the
ethics of the morality and you know what
this means for that long term you know
call it long term greed or whatever you
want to call it but how is this going to
affect our children and our
grandchildren absolutely and that is so
important they're doing that correct and
that's partly because the government
itself is kind of I don't know where
they are with this I mean oh Obama was
really good at putting together
commissions and had some actually some
really smart people working for him
and the office of science and yeah and
policy science technology and policy
whether it was but the current
administration has nobody in that office
by the way but so as maybe our
traditional political kind of structures
are not you know up to the task
necessarily or you know having some
difficulty adapting to this new world
you are having communities of smart
people who actually understand this
stuff yes and you know at least in that
case that's not happening on everything
and I I worry a lot because there's a
awful lot of other stuff I follow that's
beyond crispr that nobody really even
knows much about yeah yeah not yet we're
so so the notion of constantly keeping
our maybe our children and their
children in mind should at least make us
more aware and conscious of what we're
building and why it's important to keep
that in mind as we go forward with
technology and and even the
socioeconomic status is so that that's
that's good there's so many different
ways to maximize human potential to talk
what he thinks this has been that was a
great chunk okay let's let's talk about
let's talk a little bit about and you
can feel free to be as you don't you
restrictive on the amount that you can
share about this but we have been
talking a while about the beauty of
taking the most interesting thing about
humanity and being able to analyze it
and make it applicable to our lives
which is our data that we leave behind
mm-hmm so that's kind of something that
you're up to and whereas we have
something like genomics that is a very
static thing we have proteomics which is
a much more a thing that can a dynamic
thing somebody got up right yeah and so
so now with analyzing things like that
and being able to make my life better
your life better other people's lives
better that's kind of some of the things
that you're up to why is that so
where do you see that going with
healthcare well I've been by the way
genomics is an entirely static but it
does change of epigenetics over time but
it's mostly static and I I'm working on
a project or actually it's the second
phase of a project I started eighteen
years ago it's just hard to believe
called experimental man you know and I
was actually sequenced in 2001
genetically for a Wired story and I've
been kind of test driving different
technologies in healthcare and molecular
biology that could be tried out by a
healthy person and I wrote a book in
2009 called experimental man which won
overall at the state of the technology
at the time and it was genetics
proteomics like you said you know the
proteins in your body the metabolites in
your body
things like that but it was very early
now I could I didn't really find out all
that much but the last several months
I've been reaping again experimental Man
2 and the technology has moved ahead
very rapidly especially in the last say
three to five years and you got the
advent of I you know AI artificial
intelligence which I term I don't really
like but it's more along the lines of
you know really advanced analytics and
machine learning and deep learning
things not correct yeah so you're
actually able to begin to make sense of
some of this data so I have a massive
amount of data that I'm trying to figure
out and sift through from a number of
companies most of which are fairly new
which are offering new products and
unlike 2009 when the book came out
almost 10 years ago I actually think
that we are within say 3 to 5 years of
having products and systems for testing
it cost us one question whether
you know it'll get cheap enough for the
average person but you probably will be
able to find useful things about
yourself
yes and especially for common diseases
which has been the problem yes rare
diseases we've gotten much better at
identifying and identifying the start of
the form a nation of this problem and
this idea of radical wellness which is
the title of my current talk is that's
what it's all about
you know how do we take these new
technologies kind of radical
technologies if you will you know being
able to test not only for genomics but
all of these other omics as they're
called including the microbiome you know
the bacteria in your gut yeah that's
also behavioral data it's diet yes no
it's an experimental input yeah how much
time do you spend in the Sun you know
all of those things and somehow make
sense of that in a profile that you know
you may be able to determine that magic
moment where you go from a state of
healthiness to a state of disease long
before you show symptoms which is what
the medical system waits for now until
they really react you know to a health
situation which in some cases is it's
too late or it's pretty late yes stupid
yeah it's funny that we developed to get
to this point and not only now did we
realize that oh wait we wait until the
last possible minute well it's crazy
it's stupid now only because we have
technologies that can we can do better
with before you didn't I mean there was
no but there was no like light bulb to
be like how do we go in and figure out
when it's for when it starts rather than
when I have all these symptom so that's
that that seems to be available to more
wealthy people to start and then
hopefully less wealthy people as time
comes along it this is part partly one
of the things that will increase our
lifespan right so if you don't die from
something that if we are able to target
that thing that's causing you to die out
of right when it's starting we can make
the tweaks that prevent it from starting
and then you can live more you can
live longer so a lot of people have
conversation about okay well if we're
living longer what are we doing in our
time how are we able to provide more to
the economy during that time or to other
people how can we give more all that
kind of stuff and then furthermore will
the population be increasing as well
along the way of our planet yeah well
you know I wrote a short book about that
a TEDx a TEDx Ted book and a TEDx talk I
gave called when I'm 163 over and the
subtitle of that was the science of
radical life extension which includes
some of these things we're talking about
and what happens if it succeeds and my
real interest in that project was you
know beyond the science which is
fascinating and that was genetics and
stem cells and bionics and everything
else but there's also what happens if we
succeed yeah and it's partly what you're
asking and that's almost another issue I
mean right now we're still dealing with
horrible diseases that you know the
people die from yeah especially when
young people are struck down by cancer
things like that I mean clearly nobody
wants nobody wants that correct and the
more that we can develop technologies
that can prevent that catch cancer early
enough that it can you know hopefully be
dealt with or even with diabetes you
know which is a chronic disease for
millions and millions of people around
the world what if you could catch that
early on and you change it but I think
society does have this interesting
question on what are we actually
ultimately doing this for yeah I mean we
want to end suffering and especially yes
you know our own suffering people we
know you know anybody anybody you come
in contact with yeah I wish them is
really what and they're suffering yes
yes as a species you know it's that book
just it and and we did I I had a little
program at Berkeley at the time we did
some surveys on how long people wanted
to live and why and it was really
fascinating because nobody wants to be
sick nobody wants anybody to suffer from
illness but on the other hand most
people we surveyed
didn't want to live much past the
current life span and abri degree talks
about very interesting because he
basically says that you just want the
choice is the thing yeah you just want
the choice you don't want to have to die
at 80 you want the choice to be able to
live until 160 so that way for me I just
want to observe where society goes I
want to be a part of the growth of
civilization society in a beneficial way
so so that's always really interesting
thing about what are we in doing that
second period of like something like 80
years like what would we do how many
more times would we skydive or start a
business or when would we even start a
family would we Haven have kids what do
we what would we be doing and then how
would it affect the population of the
earth as well right and you know you
have to think about this too like if
people had to be hundred sixty-four
Albert Einstein might still be alive
CEO Steve Jobs would almost certainly be
alive I mean a lot of people that we we
admire yeah on the other hand just as
Stalin might still be alive
see ya the old dudes running things now
would be around for another hundred and
so I mean you got a kind of bad place
and they would certainly choose to want
to be around yeah and you know they
would get to have that choice of that
you know if that technology existed so
you know this is a lot of what I do by
the way and you know Aubrey hates it
when I bring that up by the way I'm
really great but I think we we just need
to think about this stuff what does it
really mean and you know you can't just
rush into a new technology and just
assume that because it's so cool and
it's at least initially seems so amazing
and helpful that there aren't downsides
almost all technology it has you know a
good and a bad yeah and sometimes it
takes a while to figure out about like
social media I think we're going through
this groove right here I mean
Mark Zuckerberg was on a cover of Vanity
Fair a year ago and the January issue of
Vanity Fair where they were talking
about he might be running for president
and I think that was the peak of him
being
you know the golden golden boy of you
know social media and technology since
then Facebook has had kind of a rough
ride this year you know what happen in
the election and the dark media and all
of this so that's just to say that you
know we just have to be aware of this
stuff and that and that goes with what
we're doing in health care too and we
talked earlier in the conversation about
this huge irony of certain parts of the
world where you brought health care with
all good intentions I mean it was
horrible watching people die of stupid
things you know confections diseases
that we got rid of in the West a long
time ago
but you and you have this irony of okay
then what yeah and so I think these
things are solvable and I think they're
actually pretty exciting to think about
and I don't know maybe it's something
that humans will do a lot better than
machines and we should be training
people to start solving those problems
and as AI takes over in certain
traditional industries so some ways I
get kind of excited I'm you know worried
on the one hand but I also get excited
that if we're aware of these things this
is why that's the part as a writer and I
guess a thinker I like to focus on you
know what are the implications of
technology and it's because if we're not
aware of them we'll be caught off guard
exactly and if we're not yeah we can
think of all kinds of new and crazy and
wonderful things yes that we can do with
them it's so important to keep an eye on
technology as it evolves and always be
conversing about where it's where what's
good what's what's not looking so good
why where we should be going with it
that's all really important okay so
let's talk a little bit about this the
cosmos are so vast and they're so vast
and there's so many other habitable
planets orbiting other stars out there
one in every five we think are we alone
in the cosmos I almost said yes to
preempt you but I didn't I thought
you're gonna ask us their life and I
you know who knows who really knows I
mean there is a school of thought that
the peculiar circumstances that created
it you know what we call intelligent
life or which is us yeah that's what we
think of as intelligent life yeah on
earth a creature just like us we could
be unique who knows we don't even really
know what I mean what forms could
intelligence take correct so you could
have intelligence all around us and we
don't even know it cuz our perception or
our senses are so limited but I don't
know I hope so I hope so kind of you
know what a waste of space down the
other hand as a historian I can tell you
that when I advanced civilizations meet
those that are not advanced correct I
wrote a book on the conquista a long
time ago on you know Hernando de Soto
and Pizarro and Cortes they did not
treat the lesser or at least in their
view lesser advanced civilization very
well we kind of don't right now either
yeah right we're talking right within us
yeah so we got a you know watch out what
we know what we hope for here at a
civilization advanced enough to find us
here get to us where we see a lot more
advanced than us or observe us even just
observing this is fun to think of we're
being observed although maybe maybe
they're more advanced on other things
that are important like morality and
ethics sir exactly I don't know I mean
they're already on other planets or on
other star systems which is a major
advancement we're trying to get to our
first other planet you know something
actually much more interesting to me
than it is there life on other planets
is what are we not perceiving and what
are we not perceiving here yeah what are
what is happening in the universe and
even around us in this room yeah we
can't perceive because of our senses or
yeah are something us are limited and
how do we augment humans to see those
yeah and I'm I'm writing this new book
on robots and part of its different
scenarios or different kinds of robots
and a lot of people I'm talking to would
like some kind of robot or system that
allowed them to greatly enhance theirs
and you know we don't even know what
that would would mean yeah and you know
we can only see your friends that's our
eyesight we can only see the visible
spectrum is tiny yeah you get thermal
and infrared and on out into the whole
spectrum and we have machines that can
see some of that you know but you know
what are we missing
yeah yeah what would life be like with
all these augmented senses I like that
how can we build that into ourselves and
then also could potentially life have
evolved in other places where those
things were maybe built into it or maybe
they augmented themselves maybe it is
likely that humans must do something
like teleport or travel at the speed of
light or something in order to unlock
other civilizations talking to us yeah
something like that there's two
hypotheses well you know people who feel
like buckaroo buckaroo banzai and if you
ever saw that silly moving it's a Peter
Weir I don't know but it was they made
this machine they could go into the
different dimension and there were all
these creatures and weird things and you
know then they came back to our
dimension but brought one of them yeah
features what you know how do we know
what we don't know it's it's right but
to me that I mean I hope they're you
know civilizations other planets I hope
we meet them I would you know love to
have a Star Trek universe where we have
warp speed and convince all these places
but I think in some ways it's far more
interesting to figure out how we could
understand what we don't we can't even
perceive right into us yeah right in
front of our faces yeah in my robot book
one of the people I talked to his Brian
Green the physicist and I'm asking
people what kind of robots that they
want to meet and he wants to meet a
robot that actually would understand how
the universe was made how it began and
how it will yeah yeah that's cool that's
where he lives
yeah you know those physicists they sit
there with their mathematics and their
equations trying to understand big
questions like that but he would just
like to know and that would of course
mean having some kind of system or
machine that could actually perceive all
of all of the stuff that's so beyond our
perception right now so another good one
is just in with perceive within
because we don't tune in enough either
we're always just taking outside in and
so by tuning in you can do things like
you can feel your actual heart which you
know beating a hundred thousand times a
day keeps you alive yeah and that's
amazing and then other things like you
can feel you so much more of the
environment around you when you're not
speaking and when your eyes are closed
and when you're just breathing and
focusing on your breath you can hear
more meditation I mean exactly you know
people could yeah I mean we already have
hints of this do we have hints it's so
interesting a different way I mean you
know another project writing project
gonna be right now the the main
character has been outfitted with
advanced prosthetics that are wired
directly into her brain and all kinds of
funky things start yeah yeah she can
begin to perceive you know we some
animals can perceive electromagnetic
waves like fish swim in unison because
they're sending out you know basically
electrical ways that are read by the
next do they stay in sync like that I
mean we have a little bit of perception
like you can kind of sense when someone
walks in a room if you're facing the
other direction mm-hmm but what if that
was greatly enhanced and you could
actually feel you know all the electric
fields that are happening around you oh
I mean just for instance so you know
that's the kind of stuff that if I
really want to go way out and your heart
beating yeah Wow
yeah I feel your heart or exactly I get
yeah I sense I can almost sense you by
the electrical field around forever so
and I wonder how far that goes like you
know Ron right now is maybe you know 12
feet or something from us yeah you know
it can we meet would we feel him
probably right has probably but it's
yeah it's very interesting okay so and
the piggybacking on the cosmic question
is the simulation question again it's
are we in a computer simulation and is
again it's not something we can touch
right it's not something we can feel
yeah which makes it difficult to address
but what are your thoughts on it
well I'm not necessarily I mean again
this conversation I had from my book
with Tim O'Reilly was fascinating and I
brought him up a couple times but he
thinks we're living in the matrix and
some others do too around here that I
talked to he doesn't mean the matrix
from the movie you know that's a virtual
reality universe argh you know we're
like sitting it actually in pods you
know it's batteries you know like like
in the movie what he means by that is
that we are humans living inside the
machine right now and you know when you
order something on Amazon you are of a
human that's making you know making that
decision but it goes out and there's a
whole mix of machines and humans that
are gonna deal with that and then it
shows up at your door and more and more
that's becoming the Machine deals with
what we've asked for correct and you
know if you think about it Google
Facebook I mean kind of these really
important entities that we I don't know
how many times you google things a day
yeah everybody and we are living in that
world already and that's not a thing you
know it's not a tangible thing like this
yeah this window here yeah it's
something but it we it's as important to
us as anything that's tangible yeah and
so we may already in that sense be
living in a form of the matrix or and
it's like a step in you know it is with
our consciousness interacting with this
digital world and you know it's I'm sure
there'll be another stab of Google glass
which by the way was the geekiest
looking thing and it was almost
embarrassing to put it on why would I
don't know is this a design problem
really you know but you know ocula you
know VR sets and I think we're gonna
more and more be incorporating that and
to like say Google search
ya know you're ordering something on
Amazon you put on your oculus and you
know your things are coming at you and
the air or whatever
I've seen some advanced VR that you
basically see the world you're in but
there might be something like a person
sitting there who's in China yeah and it
looks like they're right there
everything else is the same
and you're collaborating with them or
interacting them or and there may come a
point in the future when you kind of
wonder what what's real yeah yeah it's
taken off the opcodes to see what's
what's real so that lines getting
blurred to I think it will and we're not
there it's still really early days right
but I think more and more we're gonna
figure out ways I don't know it may stay
is our phones you know I mean this is a
form of the matrix if you will I mean I
am really connected with this thing yeah
yeah exactly
you know what would we do we can't even
remember what it was like before we had
this other things no yep I mean guy did
you have to call up a restaurant to make
a reservation you know how did you even
find out about the restaurant I don't
know you went into a magazine or a
newspaper you had to rely on the other
person arriving at the location at 6:00
p.m.
oh yeah let's meet someplace a yeah and
if they got held up or you got held up
yeah what nothing to do and in the
Turing test is also really interesting
one I think we're gonna bridging that
gap or in that line as well where I
can't tell if you're real or not if a
robot a is real or not human so oh
there's some humans I think that might
fail to direct us oh my god yeah I
really I've also got a water what that
really was I mean I there is an official
sort of Turing test but um I I don't
know I mean is Alexa okay I don't know
how much human is yeah is it parts of
the lots of it now would I mean I still
find all that monkey right yeah but you
know there will be a time I think it's
gonna come fairly soon say in the next
10 or 20 years and when it's gonna be
like you know the starship into computer
on the Starship Enterprise and you walk
into your room and you go you know Earl
Grey hot and turn up the lights really
you could already do that exactly with
your thinking and oral just know because
again your lawful ex is wired into your
you know house exactly mostly that stuff
and you I'm just recently on minefield
with Michael Stevens was learning about
how he just wear an EEG and you just
think that you're gonna press a button
and
you're trying to get to the button
before it but the button lights up red
and you gotta try and press the bun
before it lights up red but your being
red and it turns red before your his red
it turns a rude bun turns right it's
ridiculous so how much free will do we
actually have what is your stance on
that let's see I don't wanna give one
more example which I was at a party a
couple of weeks ago and a friend of mine
who works for Veritas Rodrigo Martinez
we were at that party he's always had an
Alexa or I wanna go echo home or
something
and he asked for it to give him his
genomic results cuz Veritas is a genomic
test yeah cool yeah you know like so
what was my result for whatever and you
know that was crazy I mean that's just
you know that that suggests all kinds of
interesting issues yes should Alexa but
they even have that private medical
knowledge like that but anyway so anyway
sorry what's your question then I'll
just tell you over voice whence
something is occurring inside of your
body that you should attend to right I'm
be aware of that's so good yeah it's a
good good point good good plug there so
the question was about free will how
much we will do you think we actually
have if any I don't know I mean there
certainly you know there's research that
suggested that our brains kind of make
decisions before we're entirely aware of
them
you know that's there's a controversial
there's some question as to whether that
really is true or how you you're just
talking about that yeah yeah yeah
exactly yeah you know my view is stuff
like that is so what I mean you know how
long it actually makes yeah you know
it's I I guess you know I'd like to
think I'm in control but if my brain is
more in control than me you know that's
me too I guess
in ways although I guess it bothers some
people who that's physiological and you
know it could be no different than you
know the instinct of some other animal
you know that that's just how we evolved
and this it's a total illusion that we
have free will but you know we're a
product of our genetics our upbringing
at nature nature thing there's a lot of
evidence that you know trauma even in a
recent generation like a grandparent or
great grandparent might influence us
that's not us you know that's I mean
it's crazy I think you know we do know
that we can modify behavior however so
you know you can sometimes very it's
very difficult plasticity through life
right
I mean addiction for instance can be
treated people can stop being addict yes
different behaviors positive or negative
it's amazing so yeah it can be
influenced and that you kind of you know
many ways willing yourself to a certain
way correct
and I think for now we go with that that
that we are making those things I mean
we we are deciding to do those things we
are deciding it certainly seems like it
seems like it and this may be part of
that ultimate question of what we're not
perceiving or what we don't really know
that's out there and some of that we may
not want to know but we made maybe sorry
we found out yeah yeah correct but who
knows so what is your stance on the
future of blockchain technology um I
just recently got annoyed well I got
annoyed because I could have bought some
early days and I I was I don't know well
we got alkaline of the application we
like the coin which is just yet after
currency one of them yeah I'm sorry yeah
a blockchain is so much you know as as
far as I think I still get it I think
it's yeah it's one of those fictions we
talked about earlier I think people
decide okay you know this is the way
we're gonna you know this is the way
we're going to handle medical
information for instance yeah and it'll
be encrypted and you know etc you know I
think it's an immutable link sir yeah I
mean I think we need to my understanding
of the ledger system is it's still
clunky and we probably need lots of
energy or those monopolies
around it to make it more accessible I
mean you know people trying I have
friends are trying to sell their
bitcoins and it's really hard to do
actually turns out because you know you
have to get on this ledger and all of
that and that's still early days but no
I to me it's just another system I do
worry about the people who lost their an
encryption code when they bought Bitcoin
back when it was ten bucks or something
and they stuck it somewhere it's like
you know on an oak you hear that story
on NPR yes somebody bought what was
worth like I think there's millions of
dollars now and they bought it when it
was a few dollars and it's it was on
some old computer or something which had
been wiped clean totally lost exactly so
we do have to be careful yeah I'm glad
you brought up the medical application
of it I really enjoy the thought of an
immutable ledger of me and my body and
my health records and stuff that can be
very easily accessed by the physicians
that want to help figure out the status
in my body or the AI that needs to
figure out status my body etc okay cool
and then how about what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
well we haven't covered everything yet
let's say I don't know it kind of
depends on the moment I mean it changes
from moment yeah I don't you know my my
kids you know and my kids were born or
sunset being with someone I I loved yeah
those are great
you know if ephemeral things like
flowers who knows I mean you know when
when you probably a little more
substantial I think when you feel like
you've accomplished something that's
useful or somebody else has yeah or you
have a friend or somebody you really
love it's happy those are girl oh I mean
the list goes on and on it's somebody
that thinks a lot about society and yeah
you know I I think there are some
beautiful moments when we when positive
things happen and we see
somebody achieving a you know major
innovation this it's so hard to do
breakthroughs and medicine
you know I circling back to the
beginning of the conversation I would
love to see some of these ways that we
organize and become more of a community
really start working yeah I think that
would be a beautiful exactly yeah more
collaboration more love harmony yeah
those were good as an amazing list I
think so many people agree with those
moments is very beautiful moments
especially accomplishment and
recognition just to touch into that
quick flow you're a writer and as a
writer focus is really important and
then you get into flow and then you know
don't even notice that an hour goes by
and you've written a lot and you've made
it you're happy with that how do you get
into flow how do you focus I call it
getting into the groove sometimes you're
on the edge of the grooves and as your
way out of it of it those rather
remember vinyl records you know it's
really bad when it's scratch and it goes
flying off or something like that the
record but it's for me it's a pretty
elaborate set of rituals to be honest
yeah I want to hear them let's hear your
wrist I don't know everybody's different
who runs different you know I gotta
throw the writing I've done I still find
it somewhat painful to actually start
writing I know me too and I'm I'm
working on it you know it yeah I'd like
to say that goes away the only thing
that the only thing that changes is you
actually know you probably will begin
writing again yeah you know when I was a
younger writer I would terrify when I
would go actually several days of that
really writing anything that I thought
was worthwhile and I was wondering if I
would ever get it back I'm pretty sure
now that I you know whatever is
happening that I'll be back and be
writing again I don't know I mean I used
to be an incredible slob like you know
my desk was covered with stuff I could
never find anything like yeah yeah and
weirdly the clean death syndrome like
the procrastination
has to begin every pencil has to be in
the right eye that that changed my you
know to change me from being a slob into
being pretty neat yeah and which is
funny because people who knew me like in
college are like wow that's the same
guys you've been like inhabited by an
alien or something but that's partly I
have to I don't know it's like I had
everything lined up perfect and which is
which is such a bad process for a writer
it can be great can you get everything
lined up and you know ok crap no I have
to write but the other the only thing
are actually publishing for [ __ ] and
shipping it as a writer oh my god
perfection is so bad for writing yeah
yeah well I got I mean you know I do
this as a business and as a livelihood
so I actually do have to get things in
exactly and that's actually another huge
motivation as a journalist you know I'm
a deadline guy deadlines man yeah
deadlines so for example with me you
it's you know deadlines for publication
and stuff and for me it's you set an
event to do something yeah and that
what's woods gets the fire under your
but you have to get prepared for you
have to do it there are other people
there there's people waiting for you
it's all that stuff yeah it's not just
something where you can go and lounge
off anymore so those goals so goal
setting and having a firm deadline on
that goal well on the other hand I write
books which take a year or many months
and those I have to treat like I treat
it like I'm training for a marathon or
an athletic event and I'm treating it
like a sprint right now and I need stop
you know that's like man there's madness
and that yeah I used to my first three
or four books I look like I had aged 10
years after each book and it was you
know because I I keep writing until I
dropped yeah I don't do that anymore and
you know when I used to teach writing
classes I used to say you know you I
don't sit more than two hours and write
for instance I get up I walk around one
of the reasons I sort of wander around
the city when I'm writing
yeah different cafes and things and back
to my office and yeah and if I'm if I'm
not getting something I used to hammer
away and it was such a waste of time
because like even today I you know
working on this novel I'm writing which
I start every morning working an hour on
this I wasn't getting something
yesterday and I just said okay that's
done I'm done today yeah yeah
and within 30 seconds this morning I had
the problem solved
yeah yeah exactly I let my brain you
know kind of I call it percolation I
mean it percolated and I just let it and
then you know for those people out there
that are writing want to be writers who
don't know this already writing is one
of the last things you actually do I
mean the polished finished writing it's
really got to come from your your head
yeah hard to be patient and let that
process is because I'm not really that
patient and then when does the end point
come when you actually stop because
percolation can happen after you
submitted and all that kind of stuff in
your well book hopefully you've had
enough time I mean well the okay the
other thing is structurally I those
around me see me scratching in these
little notebooks all the time I am
pretty almost obsessive compulsive over
following schedules but I change them
all the time but I map out a almost
every long project I do Excel sheets I
I'm somebody likes to check off when I
do things get things done so the more
things I had to check off the more I
feel like I'm making progress yeah
exactly
always always setting objectives
checking them off making progress that
way no do you think love is harder than
rocket science I love these questions
love is harder than well given that I'm
not trying to make rockets I suppose
love is just yes love is in my life but
not really making rockets but yeah I
think I mean I think human emotions and
doing dealing with them and human
interactions and again in this robot
book an AI book I'm dealing with things
like I'm working on a chapter on sexbots
actually about
machine love and she loved you know
there are people out there that find it
a lot easier to be in love with a
machine like in the movie her her and
then in the recent Black Mirror episode
as well yeah yeah which I haven't seen
but I want to and so you know love and
relationships and all of that with
everybody not just you know your lover
but your your parents your kids friends
all yes that is hard range you just you
just reminded me that love with your
partner that's not the only machine love
machine love could be with your parents
it could lie to me I mean that it that's
human I'm at that with humans but yeah
you could also ask those have those
machine yeah I mean all these
relationships they're wonderful and they
sustain us and you know I I couldn't
live without my friends and yeah you
know it goes back and forth I mean you
know my parents are elderly right now
and you know they're going through some
health issues it's really hard to see
these passionate beautiful strong people
getting older you know so yeah yeah I
don't know I mean it's not easy and it's
probably yeah I mean now that I'm
letting it percolate for a minute your
question I think of course love and
relationships probably the you know once
you you know got food on the table and
all of that that's probably one of the
hardest things as we do yeah yeah and
them and the most rewarding things yeah
and the most rewarding yeah yeah what's
so important to eradicate suffering from
our world and do our absolute best uh
yeah to do that I'm I'm really glad that
we were able to have all these deep
conversations that went into so many
different ways and alleys and stuff so
I'll go ahead and address our audience
at home I'll let you guys know that we
are simulation series I'm your host Alan
sake on this is our guest David Ewing
Duncan and we have a patreon where you
guys can support us and by supporting us
you get access to our guest list ahead
of time you get to know who our
is going to be you get to submit
questions and ask questions of our
guests along with getting early access
to our event info and other exclusive
content so do definitely follow us
online if you'd like to please support
us on patreon give this video a like
subscribe to our channel on YouTube
duncan de on twitter so it's duncan de
on twitter for for david and it'll
actually be in the bio as well we want
to thank bio trillion again our event
sponsor for having us here their
emerging health tech company based out
of San Francisco and another special
shout out to our director Ron Vargas
who's been crushing it on the TriCaster
so thank you guys for tuning in and
we'll see you guys again shortly thank
you